110 خطوة تنزل الآن
110 خطوة واحدة
اثنان ثلاثة تشق طريقي عبر
متاهة من
الأنفاق ، لا مكان لرجل طويل القامة
يمكنني أن أخبرك
يا إلهي كن حذرًا ، أنا سعيد لأنني حصلت على قبعتي
الممتدة من 18 طابقًا  على عمق 85
مترًا ،
هذه مدينة تحت الأرض واحدة من
أكبر وأعمق المدن في تركيا ، وقد تم
بناؤها
منذ آلاف السنين لاستخدامها في
البحث عن ملاذ من القوات الغازية.
أولًا لا يمكن إخماده
لتقديم أشخاص مثلي
إلى قلب ثقافة كابادوك ، اسمحوا
لي أن أريكم هذه المنطقة.
الحيوانات وكل شيء
يأتي أعني تخيل أن العيش
هنا ومدى خوفك
الآن لدينا مفاجأة كبيرة لك مفاجأة كبيرة
نعم تعال إلى مفاجآت كبيرة لقد وصلت إلى هذا
الحد يقول الخبراء ما يصل إلى 20  سيحشر 000
شخص في هذه الممرات الضيقة
حيث سيعيشون لأشهر في كل
مرة لتجنب قوى المغول الغازية ،
وهذا مثير جدًا للاهتمام ، فهناك
فجوة هناك وهي
مركز اتصالات لماذا يفعل كل هذا ،
نعم ،
يصرخون بعضهم البعض ، هل ذهبوا الآن
بخير الآن هذه البقعة  إنه أمر رائع
لأنني أستطيع أن أبدأ في الشعور
بما يحدث بالضبط ،
فلديك غرف التخزين في المستوى العلوي أو المستوى السفلي
لديك الأنفاق ، لقد حصلت على
الغرف المعقدة على الجانب ،
أعني أنها سويسرية  الجبن
في الأرض وكلها
غير عادية من صنع الإنسان ،
هناك مشكلة واحدة فقط لا توجد إشارة خلوية ،
أنا أمزح ،
دعنا نذهب إلى ما كان في السابق مكانًا
للجوء
الآن ، وهو مكان جذب سياحي
أعمه ضوء النهار ، أخرج من
الظلام
يا شيء شكرًا
لله  قبعتي